la force des bras et avec mille
précautions
les sculptures en bronze trouve le
remplacement elles vont désormais
s'exposer dans leur nudité originel au
regard songeur du public c'est très bien
plus loin dans le parc un torrent résine
du plus bel effet prend délicatement la
pause l'endroit est complètement magique
caroline avait raison elle voulait que
toro soir en contrepoint avec les
coquelicots les couleurs s'accordent et
on à la fragilité des coquelicots et la
force du taureau et donc le nombre est
bien choisi vous êtes ici à loire valley
lodge au coeur de la forêt delà du
portrait qui jouxte tour à 12 km qui
fait 300 hectares de forêt brut et
sauvage dans cette forêt on a invité une
vingtaine d'artistes à exposer des
oeuvres soit dans les chambres qui sont
des loges disposer dans la forêt soit
des oeuvres plus imposantes comme les
sculptures de michel audiard qui sont un
peu monumental quand même qu'ils se
trouvent dans les années et dans la
forêt
dans le vaste parc de cette résidence
hôtelière une vingtaine d'artistes
exposent leurs oeuvres parmi celles ci
une maquette de la femme loire alanguie
et suggestive certains y voyaient la
femme sublime et d'autres encore offert
à la concupiscence dix hommes ce projet
architectural de michel audiard avait
suscité une vive polémique
il ya 25 ans j'avais à rêver j'avais
dessiné et puis il ya quelques années
j'ai fait
une maquette et puis c'est devenu un
projet fou et un projet fou qu'est
devenu un projet sérieux c'est un roche
courbon que michel audiard à trouver sa
terre d'adoption et sa corne d'abondance
c'est ici qu'il a créée en 1987 il y à
34 ans sa fonderie la maîtrise du feu et
des matériaux les trépidations du métal
en fusion tout un art l'homme devient
alchimiste c'est le côté magique parce
que
seuls les dieux sont capables de
transformer les métaux sonnants et
trébuchants
quelque chose de liquide et se
métalliques ils ont le piège dans un
moule et quand il va refroidir il est
piégé dans la forme qu'on lui a donné et
après on casse pour libérer le bronze
parmi les matériaux de prédilection de
ce fondeur le travail du bronze c'est un
alliage dont il a fait sa marque de
fabrique
il en connaît tous les secrets ces
réalisations sont comme un défi au temps
on a quatre mille ans d'histoire avec le
bronze c'est la voie royale un gros il
va survivre il va être cassé on pourrait
ressouder on pourra leur patine et il va
pas disparaître il va disparaître quand
on va décider de le fondre pour en faire
des canons dans l'antre de cette
fonderie il ya une pièce qui était
jusqu'ici restée secrète et qui nous est
dévoilé comme un avant goût du paradis
vous êtes ici dans un endroit top secret
parce que c'est la seule usine d'ange au
monde
tous les anges que vous voyez partout en
fait ils sont et sortent d'ici toulouse
angers son pareil sauf qu'ils sont tous
différents parce qu'ils auront tous une
position différente bien à l'abri dans
un coffre fort une collection des fameux
stylos sculptés qui ont signé la
notoriété de l'artiste est conquis le
monde entier
un jour j'avais voulu mais j'avais la
prétention m'acheter un stylo et tous
ceux que j'ai eus étaient soit trop cher
soit me plaisait pas et je me suis dit
que j'allais en faire un mon stylo le
début d'une déferlante chacun voulait
avoir son audiard les chefs d'état comme
les artistes
de fait ce stylo à bille devenu une
marque de reconnaissance
le cadeaux protocolaires un objet
fétiche h hôtel à la signature de johnny
hallyday on a récupéré qu'on a gravé sur
la partie du calcio et puis on va on va
revenir ici avec sa guitare et comme
rien n'arrête l'imagination de michel
audiard celui ci va se livrer à une
création étourdissante la quête de
l'absolu
inestimable
ici on a on a de l'ivoire de mammouth en
ivoire de mammouth le mammouth a disparu
il ya deux mille ans on a un morceau de
météorites mort ceux des toiles on a de
l'or ont redit le matériel et spirituel
et puis on a on a cette folie qui est
une météorite qui s'appelle la météorite
de allende qui elle à 200 millions de
plus que notre système solaire la plus
vieille chose qu'on puisse toucher sur
la terre puisque c'est d'avant la terre
d'avant le soleil après 50 ans de
carrière et plus de 80 mille pièces
réalisées michel audiard est à soixante
dix ans à boulimique de travail un feu
intérieur brûle en lui c'est un
gargantua un insatiable défricheur
d'idées quand une sculpture est terminée
elle est réalisée elle ça y est c'est
fini c'est c'est la prochaine qui
m'intéresse alors l'année prochaine on a
on a une chèvre pour mettre à
sainte-maure
sept mètres de haut c'est la seule chef
qu'on voit quand on traverse sainte
maure que quand même une capitale
mondiale du fromage de chèvre voilà
c'est ça c'est cesser ses moyens pour
que je bosse il faut que j'ai dix trucs
en cours quand j'ai dit truc en cours
forcément j'en termine forcément j'en
termine 2 puis j'en ai trois cas révélés
après 50 ans d'exercice le temps qui
nous est imparti diminue fortement et
comme j'ai encore plein dans vie plein
de choses à faire je compte le condensé
je travaille de plus en plus et j'aime
ça michel audiard libre a toujours oui
et vibre encore
truculent et attachant il nous livre une
dernière dédicace comme une pirouette d'
un pied de nez à la audiard